what was the original fee
and what was the requirements
um
the original organization 20 years ago
started with people who had created net
worths of between 10 million and 100
million
and very quickly
the top end exploded with success
uh so it grew to a billion dollars and
um
more recently we've realized that our
focus is on members
between 20 million and a billion and
what i was going to say is the main
difference between
vistage and ypo and tiger 21
is the average net worth of vistage and
ypo members is probably maybe a tenth of
that or fifth of that of tiger r
[Music]
how long ago uh did you start the
company
uh about 21 or 22 years ago at this
point what was the original idea
it's really a simple idea
if you're an incredibly successful
entrepreneur
could be building a business for 10
years 20 years 30 years
and then you sell the business
you think that
it's the magic moment when you sell it
but actually what happens
is the day after you sell it
you have a lot of money but you might be
alone you might might have an assistant
but you don't have a thousand employees
you don't have anybody laughing at your
jokes anymore you might even have to get
your own coffee and everybody around you
thinks that you're wealthy and
successful but you've lost the platform
that allowed you to feel
successful and all of a sudden you're
back at a new point and the number one
challenge that you have
is to be a wealth preserver so you don't
lose what you've made
except that you don't know anything
about preserving wealth what you are is
a great entrepreneur or a great leader
or a great manager and you're good at
inspiring troops but you don't have any
troops anymore so you have this dramatic
shift
and
it turns out that what it takes to be a
great entrepreneur
might qualify you to be a mediocre
investor when you're an entrepreneur you
focus on a single opportunity you're
highly emotional about it you
you give it everything you can when
you're an investor you have to be more
dispassionate you have to have a
diversified portfolio and you have to
have you have to be unemotional about it
so the sum of it all is that there's a
little understood transition which a few
very lucky very successful people get to
go through and we wanted to study that
which is what we've done over the last
21 years to help people in that
transition uh get through it and on to a
better place
when you originally started the business
what was the uh like what was the
product was it like ypo where it was a
monthly group meetup what was it sure so
you mentioned ypo which is a fantastic
organization
there's another similar organization
called vistage and they both are for
ceos
and
uh if those are the great colleges we're
the one great graduate school and so we
have a lot of ypo members that graduate
into uh tiger 21 and a lot of vistage
members that graduate into tiger 21 uh
and just to give you an idea the uh
the v
last time i looked both vistage and uh
ypl have about fifty thousand members
globally it might be sixty now i've lost
time
vistage has fifty thousand members and
ypo each oh oh okay yeah that's about
thirty thousand each i think could be a
little more i haven't looked in a
company's company oh these are huge
businesses sure because vistage charges
like 50 grand a year right or what i
think i think i think vistage is around
15 000 or 18 i don't have the exact
number could be 20. ypo doesn't have a
single price because depending on
whether you go on the
trips and there's different people pay
different amounts but
the big difference between those two
which are great organizations is ypo is
self-facilitated
by its members whereas vistage and also
tiger 21 our groups are led by
professionals we we have over 100 groups
around the globe now and so we have a
cadre of over
40 professional chairs might be 60
excuse me 60 professional chairs that
we've trained exquisitely to lead these
incredible groups but the bottom line is
that
those are the two great organizations
for ceos and business owners and when
you decide as a rule for life that you
want to get off of the merry-go-round
for whatever reason
uh the next decision point is best uh
focused on with peers that you'll find
in tiger 21.
so basically the original premise and
you can tell me if that's still the
premises you um
you have a uh
a small group of peers i don't know how
big the group is you can tell me it's 12
to 15 people so 12 to 15 people and you
meet of some type of cadence like four
or some weeks monthly full day
and you have a coach or what do you call
your coaches facilitators
they're the chair you have a chair who
leads these discussions and
what's the original fee
and what was the requirements
um
the original organization 20 years ago
started with people who had created net
worths of between 10 million and 100
million
and very quickly
the top end exploded with success
so it grew to a billion dollars and
um more recently we've realized that our
focus
is on members between 20 million and a
billion and what i was going to say is
the main difference between
vistage and ypo and tiger 21
is the average net worth of vistage and
ypo members is probably maybe a tenth of
that or fifth of that of tiger are if
you do the math we have 140 billion
dollars under management we don't manage
it our members manage it by themselves
we're not a money manager but
collectively uh we have about uh 12 a
little under 1200 members so it's a
little over 100 million dollars per
member
that's crazy and what's the price now
the membership is about 33 000 a year
that's that's
we we try and have a kind of one price
so the only thing you pay is a single
membership fee uh unless you come to the
annual meeting there's lots of other
events that are included but because
there's hotels and all that kind of
stuff if you come to the annual meeting
there's an additional charge of a couple
grand
so i uh i i can't do the math in my head
but like that's like over 100 million in
revenue so these are like no no
so it's about a thousand it's very it's
a very simple business model it's about
1200 people that are paying a little
more than 30 000
so it's about 35 or 40 million dollars
oh i think you said 12
and uh and that's what it costs to run
that's crazy and what's crazy is 20 10
million
today is a lot it's a significant amount
of money 20 years ago 10 million was
obviously a significant more than it is
now how do you how did you find your
first
folks
so i was in a vistage group
uh which had about 15 members and in a
dramatically weird coincidence
in 1998
uh six of us sold five or six of us sold
our businesses we were all in that
vistage group because we were business
owners trying to be better managers
owners ceos
and uh we love the group and so after
our businesses were sold we didn't want
to leave the group but we found over
about a six-month period we were going
to meetings trying to figure out how to
make your cfo and your sales team and
your production more efficient but we
didn't have that anymore we were just
business we had sold our businesses so i
frankly uh said wow i'd like to be
spending time with peers but what i want
to be learning is how they're going
through this transition of becoming a
wealth manager and how they can help
each other be more successful managing
through that transition and that was the
roots of tiger 21. what was your first
business
my first business the one sorry the one
that you sold
the first business that i sold
i developed something called the
harborside financial center with a
partner we were 50 50 partners i was 25.
he was 57 it was the largest commercial
renovation in the country at the time we
bought a rundown warehouse that had been
the largest building in the world in
1929 when it was built
eclipsed a few years later by the
pentagon but it was an industrial
warehouse on the waterfront in jersey
city directly across from the world
trade center and i had the idea
literally when i was 17 because i worked
there when i was 17
that it was just 3000 feet from wall
street
and what was happening is that was in
the age of large computer centers and so
you had all the downtown wall street
firms building computer centers and if
they didn't want to be in manhattan they
would go to a far away campus on a
suburban you know somewhere in suburbia
and people felt like they weren't in
suburbia they felt they were in siberia
it was too far from the mother ship and
i had the idea that if you could put
some of those computer centers into this
huge industrial warehouse it would be
five minutes from the parent
under the hudson through the path train
and in three minutes you could get back
to whatever the parent company's
parent was and that was sort of the
original insight that this old
industrial building
had floor loads and and ceiling heights
that would accommodate raised floors for
computer centers and the weights that
you needed the weight loads the floor
loads and uh that was basically the idea
and that's the thing that you sold
before but
yeah i sold that uh when i was 30. then
i did another business that was
basically a real estate merchant bank
that acquired a lot of distressed real
estate when the real estate market
crashed in the late 80s i don't know if
you remember that the stock market
crashed in 87 the real estate market
followed and
so i was able to acquire a couple
hundred properties
from banks that had gone under and the
federal government had taken over and
when i sold that business in 1998 i said
i don't want to have to go back to work
uh
i want to know how to preserve money how
do people who've sold their business how
did they think about what they're going
to do
so that they don't take stupid risks and
find out they've lost it all has uh
building tiger 21 you you kind of
was tired 21 supposed to be a a
business earlier it's actually it's been
a labor of love for me
but
you know
oddly was it able to create more wealth
than the other things no it's uh
it's it's it hasn't at all uh basically
for 20 years i put every penny back into
tiger of revenue because i wanted to
hire some of the best people in the
world and the best teams and and get it
right but there's a lot of inherent
value in it there's no question because
uh we have extraordinary members and the
value of our franchise has to do with
our members and the team we've put
together uh was incredible but i i
realized that in order to scale the
business to fulfill its potential i
needed more senior help and in order to
attract that senior help i needed people
who were interested in equity so having
a private equity partner made it easier
to to attract world-class talent who
would uh own part of the equity
you're kind of in an interesting
position which is like you know
or you work with a significant amount of
wealthy people
and you have like some interesting
insights
where what have you seen are kind of
like the levels of wealth that someone
where like they see changes in their
life
you know
like so many things i could give you one
number or another
but it's really a state of mind you know
you you have people who
are retired and they
get x dollars and then you have other
people who are retired and they get 10x
dollars and yet the one who's
achieving or receiving the lower amount
might be more evolved and emotionally
balanced because of
meditation or work they've done
you know the most interesting thing is
there's endless studies
that show
that up to
um
that whether you ask people who earn
seventy thousand
seven hundred thousand or seven million
dollars a year how much more do you have
to earn
to be happy and the number is something
like 20 no matter where you are the
average person just needs just a little
more to be happy which tells you about
the unfilled nature of human ambition
i've read a bunch of stuff like that and
if well the way that i remembered it and
i could be wrong it was like 2x so it
was like maybe it was for net worth so
like if your net worth is a million
you're like well i would feel a lot
better if it were two but then they
talked to people who was a hundred
and
most people would say like man if you
have a hundred liquid like it's gonna be
a little bit hard to screw up but even
they were like yeah but if i had 200 i
think i would finally feel more
comfortable
you know the fact is that wherever you
are
you have the illusion that if you had a
little more it would make your life a
little easier but sometimes if you have
a little more it's a burden because now
you have to manage it and when you say
it's a burden what i mean is
intellectually you have to work harder
to make sense of it and in that sense it
is a burden it's like a job it's just
it's just in the nature of things that
the grass always seems greener on the
other side and and that's part of why i
say a lot of this is just a mindset and
there's another part which is really
important as well you know it doesn't
matter whether we're talking about 3
million or 30 million
if you take somebody if you take two
people who've worth three or 30 million
and one had been worth 50 million and
lost 20 and now there were 30 and
another had been worth 20 million and
made 10 and is now worth 30. those two
people are worth 30 million you could
use the example with 3 million as well
but the person who got to 30 million by
losing 20 feels absolutely devastated
and the person who got to 30 million by
making another 10 feels generally quite
positive or proud of themselves it's the
same 30 million so it's a lot of things
that are specific to the individual that
uh generates the psychology
there was that one article that came out
that's total nonsense it came out years
ago it said like you don't get
significantly happier after a certain
amount and the amount they said was
crazy it was seventy thousand dollars a
year but of course this was like 15
years ago
and i thought that was crazy i'm like i
don't think that's true
but
all right and i was like i do think
there is like a number where it's like
all right maybe like there's like a
threshold here where you could
definitely continue to get happy but
like there's a baseline
and um
i always thought i'm like
i think you will always want more money
but
today
maybe like if you have if you're in like
the 10 or 15 range liquid i'm like
maybe there's like all right maybe life
won't change significantly more
after that because like you know like
that's you could screw that up but like
you got to kind of screw up majorly and
but i don't know that's kind of what i
always thought
the 70 000
is a number that shows up in literature
meaning um below 70 000 every increment
that you get closer to it if you're
earning 30 000 and you get to 50 50 to
60 anything up to 70 000
increments have dramatic increases
because it's just kind of obvious it's
basic needs you need to put a roof over
your head you need to put square meals
on the table you might need a car and
it's 70 000 you can
pretty much afford most of those things
not in the lap of luxury but you can
afford those things below it it's really
really tough uh so that's kind of it
might be 90 000 today with inflation but
it's somewhere in then i don't mean to
trivialize the difference between 70 and
90. but everything above that
um you know for every level that you
have
you can just spend more and create the
same sense of being overextended if
you're not disciplined and it's the rare
person who generates excess uh capital
and doesn't change their lifestyle so no
matter how much they have they keep
spending more because if you can keep
that gap
of not needing what you have
that gives you a cushion uh that's rare
and really uh something remarkable for
those who have it have you met people
who have done that who have been let's
say worth hundreds of millions of
dollars but still live like uh don't
even live nearly like that
well you know the most classic example
would be uh warren buffett who still
lives in a 30 or 50 or 100 000 home that
he bought in
the midwest where he lives
in omaha
and
you know it's really hard to have one
person comment on another person's
health
you wonder what's all that money for
but now he's given half of it or
something to charity and there's
tremendous benefit uh gained from the
money he's given to charity but you know
it's one thing to live within your means
that's responsible it's another thing to
be so disconnected between your wealth
and what you're living
that there's something going on inside
and
you know i'll leave it to the shrinks to
figure it out
but it's kind of hard to understand why
a person who might be working 60 70 80
hours a week as if uh there's no
tomorrow and then
they might be worth a certain amount of
money but they're living on 100th of it
as if they had a hundredth
less you know they had one percent of
the wealth that they do what are they
hiding from there's lots of answers
they're all dependent on different
people
most of the people i hang out with so
i'm 32 years old i
started an internet company my co-host
sean is a little older a year or two
older than me also started an internet
company and the majority of our friends
are in like the late 20s
early 40s age and like all mostly except
for a few in the internet and so like i
run in this like very like internet
young circle and the vibe that i get
from tiger is that it's a little bit
older and more like traditional
businesses or maybe finance or real
estate who have kind of knocked it out
the park um
is is is tiger 21 mostly am i am i
categorizing it correctly or do you guys
actually have like a lot of you know
only because of only because of how
we've grown
and when you have uh you know 1150 or 60
members
um the answer is the average age
has uh fallen over the history from the
high 50s to the low 50s
but in order for it to do that given
that a lot of people stayed
most of our new members are in their 30s
and 40s so we have a lot of internet
folks but the reason they're joining
tiger as opposed to something else is
when they're sitting around they're not
just sitting with internet folks they're
sitting with people who have you know
real real estate experience and
experience running businesses uh you
know in the uh
in the in the world that isn't just from
the internet and the reason we're so
excited to have uh folks that are in the
crypto space or the internet space is
precisely because they're understanding
these new technologies that are going to
transform the world in a way that many
of our members
wouldn't otherwise so it's this
combination that makes uh some of our
meetings so electric
have you noticed the difference between
like let's just say group a is like
these people who are made their money on
the internet made their money in only
like three or eight years
uh all selling
just internet stuff so you know like not
real stuff that you can touch versus
let's say like the small business owner
who like scaled something over 20 or 30
years and then eventually sold it or
made cash flow along the way versus the
tech person who was probably poor for a
long time and then suddenly boom they're
not have because they sold their
business and they weren't ever
profitable but have you noticed a
difference in those people's attitude or
the problems they have
well they're probably
you know as many differences as there
are people but there's some fundamental
truths that i think you're pointing at
you know um
when i went to business school at uh mit
40 some years ago
you know if you were doing a marketing
exercise they'd say come up with a
product that you could sell to a
thousand people and today if you go to
stamford to a marketing course they say
come up with a service you could sell to
a billion people literally a billion
people that's what facebook does and
some of the other major social media so
scaling
is not just a difference in size
we have a dramatically more frictionless
economy the nature of internet and
technology
allows businesses to scale that's why we
have unicorns today but we almost never
did in the past
so when you think about life
expectations people who started out 30
or 40 years ago had an expectation that
they'd be they'd have to put their nose
to the grindstone for 30 years before
they'd hit a payday uh not all of them
but some of them and of course there are
many different types of wealth i
distinguish between people who are
workers versus people who have some kind
of god-given talent a singer a
basketball player an actor
a rapper these are people not who are
building businesses but have god-given
talents that of course they have to work
hard to hone those talents but it's very
different when your wealth is created
from your own talent than when you have
to scrimp and save you know to make a
payroll and and get everything done but
then if you compare that to people who
are creating wealth today first of all
they can do it in three to five years
you have unicorns in you know three to
five years or
uh not much longer and so
one of the big differences is that
if you were 58
20 years ago and you sold your business
you probably were retiring because you
spent 30 years doing something
and that was your first sale but today
if you sell
you might be 30 or 35 or 38 you're not
retiring you're going on to the next
thing so the i think the biggest
difference is this kind of expectation
of what a life looks like
you know a generation ago a really
successful entrepreneur had one or maybe
two
serial successes today a successful
entrepreneur could have three four or
five or multiples because he or she has
figured out how to manage a couple at
the same time
elon musk is not the only person
who has
multiple businesses he's certainly the
most visible but it's much more creature
of today
it happened in the past but just much
less so when i was selling my business
i would talk to some bankers and i would
talk to some friends and advisors
and a nice amount were like yeah sell it
and get paid and like you know you don't
have to worry about money anymore and
that's wonderful and then the other
group of people that were like
uh man starting something that works is
really really really hard
and
a lot of people sell a business and want
to start it again and they don't realize
like you know like there's some luck
involved and it's just
actually really really challenging and
sometimes you get confident you think oh
i can just do it again
and so if you don't have to sell it
never sell it and i've lately fallen in
the category of like if you don't have a
lot of money sell a company if you if
that means that you're like financially
secure
but then after that oftentimes try not
to sell anything ever
like to see if you can just like run it
or get it to run it on its own or hire
people because it's quite hard to get
getting something going it's such a pain
in the butt do you fall do you tend to
uh
when you're talking to your members do
you
what do you think most like which of
those categories do you think is
actually a little bit more true or more
common and uh i think you're on to
something really important and it's kind
of like all of the above
one of the biggest
learnings is that most people who sell
their first business
have no idea
that it feels like having the rug pulled
out from underneath you
because you see a big dollar amount and
and you're so focused on the sale
that it's the everything else that's
kind of the shock and uh the most
important one is the momentum or the
platform that you don't even realize how
valuable it is so you know one of the
things we really talk about is before
you sell you really have to think about
not just the pros
but the cons and and
particularly in an environment like
today forget that the markets are down
this year in a low interest rate
environment
when you sell
you know a typical industrial building
obviously uh you're talking about um
other other types of metrics but it used
to be a typical meat and potatoes
business would sell for seven or eight
times earnings
and you know if you take a business that
was making i'll use an example three
million dollars and you sold it for 20
million dollars and you paid the taxes
now you have 16 million
but if you buy bonds at 2 percent you're
now making
320 000 on that same
capital that was generating 3 million
dollars before you've lost 90 percent of
your earning power and we call that
sticker shock and 90 i would say the
vast majority of people who sell their
first business
go through sticker shock because they
haven't really thought through
that the passive earnings on the profits
of the sale
will generate dramatically less income
than the business itself did now of
course the positive is that when you get
when you sell that business you don't
have all the risks of that business and
maybe the business had risks that could
put it out of business so a good sale
allows you to take chips off the table
and that has a lot of benefits but i
think you're really
you know you're on to the central
issue around selling businesses
because particularly
if you hold on to the business you don't
have a tax liability i'm not against
taxes in general i'm just saying that it
eats into some of the value whereas if
you continue to own the business
the full value is working to make the
business larger and larger
so when you're thinking about risk
um i think the greatest service that we
do is help some of our members think
about the things they hadn't thought
about when they're thinking about
selling like what
well just what we're talking about this
sticker shock this this sense of
do you really want to lose the platform
uh that you have and will you have
enough capital because we've had many
examples of people who think when they
sell the business it's going to be easy
street but when they don't realize the
loss of income that occurs
when you're taking dollars from a sale
and putting it into passive assets or
worse in order to generate income like
they had before they take risks they
don't understand in investments because
investing can be a lot harder you know
when you own a business it's kind of
like being on a dog track a dog track
you have a fence to your left and a
fence to your right somebody shoots a
gun behind you and you can only go
forward you know if you're a paper clip
manufacturer or you sell rocks or
frankly even an internet service you
have one direction you want to be the
master of whatever your business is and
that's really hard
but intellectually when you're an
investor how can any one person
understand all the markets and if you're
starting out with no fundamental
understanding of the markets because
you've just been running a business
one of the real shocks
is most people think the hard part is
making the money and then once you have
the money you're on easy street but from
an intellectual challenge point of view
many of our members find
the challenge of managing the wealth
that they've created is actually
intellectually more challenging
than the business because the business
might have come naturally to them they
might have had an idea and they just
pursued it to its uh good ends when i
sold i mean i didn't know it this was
only a year a year and a half ago or a
year and a couple months ago i didn't
know anything like i i mean i knew
nothing like i didn't know like when
people said that they're going to short
a stock i was like
i don't know what shorting means and
they say they're gonna go log i'm like
don't know what that means and so uh
like it was
and people
like you know friends and family were
like well what are you gonna do with
your money and i'm like i don't i don't
know anything like i i i think people
are surprised that your ability to earn
is not often correlated with your
ability to like invest
uh just the opposite that's that's what
i'm trying to say you can be a great
entrepreneur and a really lousy investor
and you know just to give an expectation
for
uh people who might be listening how
long do you think
it takes to go from being a successful
entrepreneur that is a mediocre investor
where you were a year ago how long do
you think it takes till you have sort of
a modicum of confidence that you know
what you're doing as an investor
i mean years i don't know i mean i've
been studying it now for a year and a
half and i feel like i don't know much
five years
five years yeah that's and that's if
you're really working at it
what i just did was put so i are you
familiar with hubspot
sure so they're the ones who bought it
so i own hubspot stock and then the rest
was just mostly a vanguard total index
fund and some real estate and real
estate funds what uh
with your folks
what do you what's like the asset
allocation of like uh uh what you've
seen what's like a fairly successful
sure
so
yeah i want to be really we're not an
investment advisor but i do track the
asset allocation of our members and can
simply report on it which is yeah you
guys put out this annual report that's
awesome i love that so the the asset
allocation very roughly
is uh traditionally real estate has been
king with about twenty eight percent of
the assets maybe twenty seven uh is that
a good uh primary residence no
generally not um it's it's mostly
investment real estate and does that
mean they own it or they're in a ring
it could be they're in a reit more
likely they either own a building or
they own a limited partnership in a real
estate fund of some sort
second would be public equity
um about 26 20 anywhere between 24 and
that's so much lower than i thought
exactly and private equity and this is
unique to the tiger community uh our
private equity has for the last couple
years been more than public equity it's
now a little neck and neck but private
equity is around 21 to 24
and what's so remarkable is if you take
those three numbers the private equity
public equity and real estate it adds up
to 70 plus percent those are the risk on
assets so our members are relatively
long-term bullish
on investments even when they think
we're going into a recession they still
are over 70 percent invested in
when i say risk on assets that's what
the you know the investors say are
assets that
are risky and have to do with
business-like qualities then a fixed
income until you know now is at a
historic low point about seven
seven percent it was as high as 12 or 14
in prior years uh and crypto and gold
creeping up one or two percent assets
each
and
cash at uh 12
our members cash has stayed relatively
fixed over a long period of time
the biggest it typically fluctuates
between 11 and 13
but in the um
pandemic
march of uh 2020 it spiked to 20
which statistically is off the charts
that's how concerned our members are but
generally in the 12 ranges is uh what
our members are looking at in cash what
do they love about real estate so much i
mean and
uh it's the gift it's the gift that
keeps on giving and first of all they're
terrific tax attributes of real estate
because of depreciation
but
you know when most people think of an
investment asset and they buy a company
that company is subject to competitive
forces every single day it's why most
operating businesses don't lend
themselves to
multi-generational families of course
there are exceptions and some very
important ones but real estate is a much
more
tolerant asset for multi-generation or
or if you own certain uh natural
resources you know if you own uh
timberlands those are good to pass from
generation to generation because when
you own a great piece of real estate you
know the joke is your child can be
let's say less than brilliant and still
know how to collect the rent and even in
your own lifestyle if you own a great
piece of real estate the tenants have to
pay the rent even when you're playing
golf but when you're running a
complicated technology company or
something else you got to be out there
and working every day your team has to
be really really good and i'm not in any
way suggesting real estate
it takes a different kind of unique
smarts it's not an easy game
but it's very different
one way to think about it is if you took
the whole economy i don't know if you
remember the dewey decimal system of
libraries but if you broke the economy
into all of its sectors and one of those
sectors was real estate and nine other
sectors medical and education
everything else high spec high tech
aerospace etc if you took those nine
other categories real estate
is more different than those other nine
than any of the other nine are to each
other because of this durability this
multi-generational capacity of real
estate we always make a joke that people
they get offended about this but i'm
like it's kind of a compliment we always
say that real estate has the highest
number of dumb rich people uh
and that was kind of like
a fox in other words they may not people
who have the same intellectual pursuits
that you are right but they can go and
smell an opportunity and sniff out where
there's a problem in a way that most
other business owners don't and that's
why i say it's very deceptive because
they're a breed apart but that's become
a little less so in the last generation
because as real estate became more
securitized
with different types of
ownership and debt that went to wall
street it became more of a wall street
game so it's a little more today a wall
street game than it was 20 years ago
yeah and the the the kind of the
strategy that my wife and i had was
let's just try to get
somewhat wealthy with tech stuff and
have that continue to make cash flow and
and
you know selling companies and pile a
lot of it into real estate because
that's something because like with my
business we had to send an email every
day but if gmail changed like it could
go out of business a building that i own
i could lose a fair amount of money on
it but like there's it's still a thing
that someone will purchase even if it's
at a huge loss but it's not gonna go to
zero whereas my company it definitely
could like if i owned a conference
business and a pandemic hit like which i
did
uh like it went it literally made zero
dollars whereas this land that i own
that i'm looking at right now like
that's probably not gonna go to zero
you know
none of these things are as simple as
we'd like i think you're making some
really excellent points
but if you owned retail
or
movie theaters uh or airports in the
pandemic that went to zero too if you
had any leverage on it so it's not that
realistic being hyperbolic but like you
know i understand yeah i totally get it
it's not that it's without risk but as
an asset category it's a long dated
asset
i can't find this client info have you
heard of hubspot hubspot is a crm
platform so it shares its data across
every application every team can stay
aligned no out-of-sync spreadsheets are
dueling databases hubspot grow better
[Music]
uh
one more thing about the selling and uh
selling versus not selling because you
have a way bigger sample size a do you
regret selling your companies and b
the thing about selling like
let's say that you sell a business and
you make 30 million you pay taxes now
you're left with 20. to make 20 million
like you could build a business for 5 or
10 years sell it and
make that
to make 20 million after to make 20
million from cash flow annual cash and
that's
really freaking hard
like
you gotta i mean your taxes are higher
because it's income versus capital gains
but and you i mean it's just like it
just seems like
selling a business is probably the e the
easier of the two and it's still not
easier
it's still not easy it's the easier the
tomb to to accumulate like your first
bit would you agree with that or no well
it it's it's the problem is
that it's better to think of it as a
shift in risk
because when you made the decision to
um
sell for 30 million the example you just
gave
what you've done is you've taken a lot
of risk on the table so the chance of
losing that 30 million now goes down
radically it's much less once you've
turned it into cash
but the chance of getting to 60 million
might have gone down also because you
lost the engine of growth so it's you
know do you want to sleep well or do you
want to eat well are you long-term
greedy or short-term greedy but there's
no question that
when you sell your business
in my opinion more often than not it's
it's not number dependent it's risk
dependent you want to take risk off the
table you don't want to you don't want
to have the risk just as you said of
losing your business anymore so you can
take your chips off the table and
diversify it over a number of
investments
but it's going to be much harder if the
business was
a well-functioning growing business to
get to that you've you've increased the
hurdle rate before you can get to that
next level of 60 or 80 or 100 million
dollars
do you regret selling your two things
um and tiger
um or so you didn't sell it first of all
i'm still the chairman and majority
owner of tiger but it's run as if i'm 50
50 partners and tiger would be a great
example um
i'm 66
and
the when i sold tiger the risk that i
was most concerned about because i'm a
cancer survivor is
longevity and sustainability if
something happened to me so our board
said i was the number one risk and
because i love this business i said well
how do i how do i do how do i reduce
that risk well the first thing is i
bring in a co-owner and the second is we
bring in a world-class ceo
and in order to bring in that
world-class ceo i needed to bring in a
co-owner
so tiger is immeasurably stronger today
from a team point of view and an
ownership and a resilience point of view
it is still my legacy i'm the founder it
was my idea but i never went into it for
money and i'm not sure that i would have
done any better on my own i think i
think the the diversity of ownership and
uh the addition of a team that we built
into a world-class team is just
dramatically different than i could have
created on my own so i have no regrets
whatsoever uh with tiger and um
with the other businesses it was
interesting i sold my first project that
i mentioned to you when i was 30.
um
and
what did you
can you say what you sold it source so
we have contacts i mean it was uh it was
a project that i was a partner in but
the project got sold for over 100
million dollars and
the and that was in 1987.
that was pretty life-changing i'd
imagine uh totally life-changing um but
the point is that
um
what i remember is not so much the
dollar amount what i remember is it was
heralded as the most successful real
estate project
in metropolitan history in terms of
financial return
and
um
so
uh but but it took me a couple years to
kind of
find myself again because i went from
being one of the top hundred developers
in the country i also had the advantage
i had a partner
the project was my idea
but selling was his idea
and he never would have got into that
project if he hadn't been my partner and
i never would have sold it if i hadn't
been his partner and we sold at the end
at that point a hundred percent 99
of what we were worth was tied up in
that project and if somebody had got
hurt or killed in construction you know
it could have it could have wiped us out
and so we sold and we closed in january
of 87 and in october 87 the market
crashed and
real estate followed after that and we
had been one of the top 100 developers
and we might have been one of five
developers in the whole country
that had lots of capital and no
buildings to weigh us down with the
problems from the market crash so that
gave us an extraordinary opportunity to
get back in at the bottom
and i did that by creating a company
that bought distressed real estate from
banks and went on to buy close to a
billion dollars of what became a billion
dollars of assets wow
when
when people
one of the surprising things when i
kind of started
when when i sold was i had never heard
of this thing called an asset-backed
loan which is like basically one example
of that is when rich people buy a home
you'll hear that they bought like a five
or ten million dollar home in cash and
oftentimes what that really means is
they're using this thing called an asset
backed loan so basically if you have a
stock portfolio of
10 million dollars and it's like in a
vanguard index fund or some basic thing
like that you can borrow like 60 or 75
percent of that at
a given a very very low interest rate as
low as one percent
um what was uh what were some some what
are some surprising things that people
who come into money after selling their
company that they that they see and
you're like
like when i when my banker told me about
that i was like are you kidding me this
is like this is how people do it this is
amazing what are some other things that
kind of fit in that category so i'm
sorry but i would never do that most
tiger members yeah most tiger members
wouldn't for two reasons one
uh i don't have any debt i wouldn't want
any debt it debt can be very corrosive
at exactly the wrong time you know the
market has just gone down for people who
are levered they could have been wiped
out if you want to be here for the long
term and preserve wealth i would argue
you want as little debt as possible
i'm not suggesting that's a good idea no
no no no no i don't understand it's an
interesting option that people have like
needs to pay taxes sure
but the other the other part of it is
that one percent can be illusory because
the rate can go up if it's a floating
rate and if you have a spike in interest
rates and you made assumptions that you
were borrowing at that low interest rate
and then it goes up you can really wreak
havoc with your balance sheet so i uh
one of the things
that most tiger members enjoy when they
reach a level of wealth is the ability
not to have debt hanging over them now
having said that
who are the best managers of debt well
private equity firms and real estate
is the place where most debt is so
people who've spent a career managing
debt understand the power of it but they
just understand that at some point you
want to reduce risk
and take chips off the table i think the
other thing is something you said before
not everybody fully appreciates
why they became successful because for
every person who had a plan
somebody else was
lucky let's say doesn't mean that they
didn't have a plan but fundamentally
they're lucky and it's just a
statistical thing the the number of
people who've had two successes is
dramatically smaller than the number of
people it's a bell curve of who's had
one success and for people to have three
and four successes gets down into the
you know one in a thousand entrepreneurs
or something and i think that um
many people
systematically overestimate their own
skills when they've been successful
and there's a real comeuppance that
after they sell their first successful
business they assume they'll be
successful in the next one and they get
their clock handed to them as i did when
i was 30. it was a very painful lesson
but it was the most valuable lesson well
i uh sold this amazing project
uh when i was 30 and then i started a
business in the real estate information
this is before the internet you know
pretty much what zillow is today where
you can look up any house and get a
price on it we created a business that
was a precursor to zillow before there
was an internet it was so much
of your net worth from the previous
thing did you invest into this new thing
oh
i probably risked
somewhere between 20 on the order at 25
something like that and so one of the
biggest
one of the biggest um
uh
learnings
is
when you
sell a business you know many people
think they're great investors because
when they own a business if they make an
investment they have to talk about it at
a cocktail party and if they lose in
money on an investment it gets swept
under the carpet because the business
itself
is profitable so it covers up those
losses so many people who've been
successful entrepreneurs don't realize
how poorly they are as investors because
they've never been battle tested without
the benefit of the company providing you
know the fill if you make a mistake so i
think i think the one of the biggest
mistakes that people who sell business
make and it's what you said before
is that they're uh that they assume they
can do it again and again and only a
portion of people who've been successful
once are going to be successful twice
we're talking about earning money what
about spending money uh
like something that i
ask myself is
i'm quite frugal and i say like i don't
want to buy this this and this because
it costs too much money and i just don't
it just it and some stuff like owning um
you know a lot of like objects in my
home it kind of just stresses me out
because i feel like i got to take care
of it but then there's other things like
flying nicely or staying at fancy hotels
where i was like i don't want to spend
money on that and then i was like well
you know what that actually makes me
happier like this is fun for me i should
spend because that i feel like you know
about the marshmallow test
yeah about uh um delayed gratification
yeah delayed gratification so should i
tell it for your life
it's a very famous uh very famous test
that was done at stamford uh in the i
think 50s or early 60s and you know they
put a table of 12
three-year-olds or four-year-olds out
and they put one marshmallow in front of
each of the kids and they said
look i'm going to step out of the room
if you don't touch the marshmallow while
i'm gone
when i come back i'm going to give you
another marshmallow and only one or two
of the kids could
wait
for the person 20 minutes to come back
they just had to eat the marshmallow in
front of them those one or two could
handle delayed gratification and it
turns out that they tracked
many kids who went through this and the
very few who could delay gratification
were more successful in school more
successful in life and more successful
in business by various measures
over the next 30 to 50 years of their
life it's a remarkable study and it has
to do with what i was saying before when
you're an entrepreneur as apparently you
were
you had to delay gratification because
you were putting money into your
business you couldn't you couldn't do
all the things others who were making a
lot less but didn't have a business
we're doing and delayed gratification
the discipline of delayed gratification
is at the core of uh entrepreneurial
success but frankly when you're
a movie star or a rock star or a
baseball pitcher or a basketball player
delayed gratification isn't so much at
the core of your success because you
don't need to scrimp and save you need
to practice and be well
so when people sell you know there's a
syndrome where somebody's been very
successful but they've been delaying
gratification so long that they only
open up one step at a time they still
are driving a chevy they still are
wearing a certain kind of suit they're
wearing a timex watch but they go on a
great vacation or they go on a mediocre
vacation but they're wearing a really
expensive watch you find when people
have sold their business they open up
slowly because
they want to they want to be smart and
they don't want to waste and they have
to find that new balance but you know we
have a rule at tiger which i think is
the most important rule it's called the
two percent rule if you've been lucky
enough to sell a business one gauge you
can think about is if you're solely
uh living on the investments in your
portfolio
if you can live on two percent of your
assets or less
then you're in a safety zone
and obviously some people have the good
fortune to earn a lot more than two or
three or four percent on their assets so
they can live on a little more but once
you start living on more than two
percent you're actually starting to
stress the ability to preserve capital
and my guess is if you if you went to a
whole bunch of 25 year old kids and said
you know if you inherited a million
dollars how much could you spend a year
and preserve the money you'd be shocked
a lot of kids would say i don't know a
hundred thousand or two hundred thousand
a year
it's twenty thousand a year and uh that
learning is really fabulous
uh there's this um
funny cool subreddit subreddit a reddit
a forum that i go to
and it's called fat fire you know you
know what fire is like fires like
financially independent retired early
fat typically fires like people who
want to save like a million dollars and
live off like 50 000 a year fat fires
people who want to like earn a huge you
know a much larger amount and live
somewhat lavishly and on that subreddit
the number is like three percent so it's
a little bit higher than two percent but
like three percent i think there was
this thing called the trinity study and
they said like four percent frankly i
think that sometimes is too high but
like i i i kind of buy in the three
percent range and uh anyway there's this
one book have you ever heard this guy
named felix dennis no i don't think so
he's amazing he's kind of he's dead now
but he's kind of like a combination of
mick jagger and richard branson so he
was this he was this british
entrepreneur and he was kind of
flamboyant like richard branson and like
did a bunch of stuff but he was like
mick jagger and that he was like kind of
a degenerate like he loved drugs and
hookers and he was like he wrote about
like his escapades when he got older he
was like i had a drug problem and i was
never married so i was just like
sleeping around and so he's kind of like
a fun guy to read about but he's got
this book called uh how to get rich it's
kind of poorly titled in a way that it's
like embarrassing to talk about but it's
quite a good book
and he was like he he eventually founded
um
micro warehouse which was a publicly
traded company but he also started maxim
magazine he was a publisher so he made
all of his money in magazines
and he was like so i'm going to die soon
because i've got cancer and i'll die
with like a 600 million net worth but if
i could do it all over again my goal
would have been to make 20 or 30 million
dollars by the age of 35 and not focus
on money making ever again and only
focus on
uh like the people i cared about but
like a boxer who's punk uh punch drunk i
went back into the ring every time
because i was addicted to it even though
it it didn't always bring me the most
amount of fulfillment and happiness i
just want to share three reactions to
that the first is there was a band
leader from the late 60s or early 70s
who was being interviewed a few years
ago and the announcer said you know you
were the first band to make a million
dollars a month no band had ever made
that much money what'd you do with all
that money you guys must be rich he said
well we spent about 70 percent on wine
women and drugs and wasted all the rest
but the thing is the uh the thing with
mick jagger is what you don't see is he
like works out six hours a day he uh he
he eats a food regimen that's like
second to none and here's a guy who's
maybe keith was a better example yeah
well
that's important because even with
richard branson with with his
whatever your persona is you know he
knows how to lever uh from a marketing
point of view he puts like nothing into
a business and others invest around his
name so his risk is very low these are
these are people who are real geniuses
at what they do but the thing that the
thing that you didn't mention
is philanthropy like how does people
create meaning
i i think that people who've created a
certain amount of wealth and then say a
higher percentage of what i'm going to
make i'm going to give back to causes
that i believe in and try and make the
world a better place i think that's a
really important way to get meaning so
that guy who made 600 and said i should
have just made 30 maybe he should have
just been a little more philanthropic
and and looked around the world and said
i can make an impact in a positive way
have you heard of this book called you
got a ton of books behind you so maybe
you have
it looks like you read a lot there's
this book called um
dying with zero it's by this hedge fund
guy named bill perkins and i've just
started reading it but it sounds like
the premise of the book is basically
like
uh spend like if you're going to give
instead of giving away money when you're
dead like give your kids the money now
so if they want to buy a home or do
something like maybe you can
enjoy it together if you want to leave
money to a certain cause just give it
now because you'll be able to see you'll
be able to see it and you can all get a
little more joy out of that sure
that was the biggest debate
you know for many years warren buffett
said i'm leaving a big foundation when i
die
and
he said because i'm growing my capital
so quickly
that by leaving it in my portfolio i'll
leave so much more and bill gates made
the argument with him yes but what's the
value of a life saved today versus a
life only saved 30 years from now when
you die and some things aren't financial
calculations so the point that you're
making is there's a lot of value to
being philanthropic both with your time
and your money earlier on and not just
uh later on and i think
one of the things that
is really important is many
entrepreneurs have a lot more than money
they have skills and insights and
contacts that they can lever
philanthropically so i do believe uh in
being as active as possible uh to make
climate is my number one issue and so
i'm involved in climate both politically
philanthropically and in the way i
invest and that's given me a lot of
feeling at least of i'm doing as much as
i can
well last two questions
first um
the interesting thing about this your
business tiger 21 is
from an outside it seems like the it
seems like the vast majority of the
value is your like eight or ten person
or 15 person
your group
which means
i would think that there's a lot of
pressure or not pressure but there's a
lot of faith that the facilitator like
you need that facilitator to be good and
if your facilitator stinks and that
could potentially ruin
the experience
so which almost is like your business is
almost decentralized or like it you know
customers will have drastically
different experiences potentially
regardless of what's happening at hq how
are you how do you make sure your
facilitators are good and are providing
a valuable experience so i think what
you're searching for is kind of a
classic example of would you rather own
300 gas stations or one oil refinery if
they're both worth the same amount of
money well the answer is obvious on that
one i think which is what
multiple i mean it's like you don't want
you don't want you don't want uh
all your you don't want one big ass
customer you would be nice to have a
hundred
more that are equal but the fact is if
you have 300 gas stations that have all
the same label on them the same name
you have a brand exposure that if
something bad happens in one of them it
could affect uh people's demand for the
other so
our only asset is our people both our
team our chairs that facilitate the
groups and our members and we spend we
have like a private university we spend
fortunes of time screening the
facilitators and then
providing lots of opportunities for the
facilitators to learn from one another
our facilitators come in from all we
call them chairs of the groups they come
in from all over the world
to learn best practices from each other
and we track all of the relevant metrics
to see which groups are performing well
which groups are not performing well and
of course the most important thing is
that
we have zero tolerance
for
uh anything less than high integrity and
maintenance of confidence if somebody if
a member or a chair
ever violated that they would be out in
a second so i'd say that maybe uh
besides the core asset
uh being our
team and our members
the thing we protect the most is our
brand by being really true to what what
it stands for and i don't think we've
ever compromised on trying to put
members first that's that's kind of what
we're about i'm a member first all most
of the value that i've gotten out of
being a member of tiger has been being a
member uh the fact that i've owned today
a little more than half the business is
almost irrelevant to the value that i've
gotten by being a member and all the
opportunities that i share with all the
other members that come my way as a
member well you're awesome the reason i
wanted to talk to you was because i've
uh i know of tiger i've thought about
joining i've got friends that are part
of it and i love the business model my
business was was
tangentially related but not quite the
same thing it was community based and
i hadn't read or seen too many
interviews with you and so i'm happy
that we got to talk because uh
i wanted to kind of explore this but
you're you're you're uh you're cool as
hell i appreciate you taking the time
this is awesome thanks so much for
having me and if you if people wanna do
you use twitter or anything if people
wanna find you do you wanna point them
anywhere
um i'm on linkedin i don't use twitter i
don't i i
i don't use facebook um but i'm
available through linkedin and uh
it's kind of easy it's
michael.sonnenfield.tiger21.com
hell yeah thank you man i appreciate it
thank you
[Music]
you